welcome to Hannity buckle up tonight
another big breaking news night we have
a lot of ground to cover moments ago as
you just saw at the end of Tucker the
president wrapping up his massive rally
this time in Hershey Pennsylvania early
this morning as per usual thousands and
thousands lining up outside in the
freezing cold and rain to get a spot
inside the arena Trump supports
reporters are clearly motivated maybe
the media is not noticing in fact the
president is now polling well ahead of
his Democratic opponents in these key
swing states Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Michigan and other battleground states
will show you those numbers in the
course of the program plus we will have
reaction to the Democrats in sanity
there you know Ukrainian conspiracy
theory impeachment coup attempt and how
illegitimate and frankly almost
laughable what it is now descended into
and quote articles of impeachment we
will try to do the impossible and detail
each and every single lie from that guy
we're going to expose him we've been
telling you he's compromised he's
corrupt and a congenital liar
tonight we prove it but first as we have
been telling you for over two and a half
years our top story tonight
the single biggest abuse of power
scandal corruption scandal in American
political history our country's most
powerful tools of intelligence were
weaponized against a private citizen and
a presidential campaign transition team
and president this all in 2016 and 17
and we will write president Trump was
right the Attorney General bar was right
spying occurred we told you the mob
didn't believe it but it's all true
take a look do you still stand by your
statement that the campaign was spied
upon it's clearly spied upon I mean
that's what electronic surveillance is I
think wiring people up to go in and talk
to people and make recordings of their
conversations is spying I think going
through people's emails which they did
as a result of the FISA warrant they
went through everything you know from
from pages life he wasn't in the
campaign at the point where no began the
survey yes but his emails were go back
so while the mob and the media they
chased their own tail breathlessly
obsessing about one hoax and conspiracy
theory after another we on this program
we never relented we unpeeled every
layer of the onion we covered this very
real abuse of power this very real
corruption scandal perhaps the biggest
in history a scandal that now the
Attorney General the United States just
called intolerable he's right these are
powerful comments pay close attention
these comments are not made in a vacuum
this is the Attorney General of the
United States he knows more than all of
us on this take a look I think our
nation was turned on its head for three
years I think based on a completely
bogus narrative that was largely Flamm
fanned and hyped by an irresponsible
press and I think that there were gross
abuses of FISA an inexplicable behavior
that is intolerable in the FBI we repeat
for two and a half years our ensemble
cast we got the crap beat out of us
every day we were beaten up we were made
fun of it's all fine I don't really care
what anybody says anymore but you we the
people we were right every step of the
way and the Inspector General's FISA
abuse report while limited in scope
confirmed and reveal major facts one and
we've been telling you
Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
dirty Russian dossier lead it was
central it was essential it was almost
the entire FISA application against
Carter page the backdoor into the Trump
campaign transition team and even
presidency without the dirty dossier as
we told you there would not have been
any FISA warrant second the so-called
intelligence in the dossier was nothing
but garbage lies conspiracy theories
uncorroborated garbage based on one
single source never corroborated never
verified in fact as we told you it was
unfair
fireball third the dossiers author
Christopher Steele said his single
source was an egomaniac that liked to
boast and fourth steals single source
told the FBI that his or her claims were
never corroborated were never conclusive
and were based on word of mouth or
hearsay and a crude joke at the bar
especially remember the hookers Moscow
ritz-carlton yeah all of that
information totally admitted from the
FISA applications on purpose
that would mean premeditated fraud
perpetrated repeatedly on the FISA Court
and according to the Inspector General
there were at least 17 significant
failures inaccuracies and omissions by
the way hey super Patriot Jim Comey
that's your FBI that's you you did that
you hurt the premier law enforcement
agency of the world not the rank and
file they are fantastic
you signed off on three of the four or
five applications you never verified it
because it was unverifiable you knew
full well that the information provided
was never close to being vetted true or
accurate and that it was unverified and
under commis corrupt malignant
leadership high-ranking FBI officials
again not the brave men and women in the
best law-enforcement agency in the world
those top guys knowingly misled that
FISA court repeatedly they knowingly and
purposely we learned yesterday and today
omitted exculpatory evidence they
knowingly suppress information about the
reliability of Steele's principal source
they even altered things an AG bar is
now saying commis FBI well well they may
have been acting in bad faith that's an
understatement take a look here to me is
the damning thing they not only didn't
tell the court that what they had been
relying on was it was completely you
know rubbish they actually started
putting in things to bolster this deal
report by saying well we talked to the
sources and they appeared to be truthful
but they don't inform the court that
what they're truthful about is
is is false so that's hard to explain
and the core statement in my opinion by
the IG is that these irregularities
these misstatements these omissions were
not satisfactorily explained and I think
that leaves open the possibility to
infer a bad faith
what is bar really saying here the Comey
is now a likely subject and the Durham
bar criminal probe I guess he didn't get
the memo because mr. super Patriot he's
out there taking a victory lap living in
his conspiracy theory world and praising
his home courageous leadership in the
Washington Post mr. Comey I've warned
you about this before you might want to
hold off on popping the champagne and
guess what you have the right to remain
silent and I suggest you might want to
do that we have a clear pattern now of
willful misconduct Kolby Brennan clapper
and all these other top officials in the
Obama administration and one of the most
damning pieces of evidence is the fact
that no one inside the Trump campaign
they never went to the Trump campaign
the candidate Trump he's a patriot and
warned the Trump campaign about this
counterintelligence investigation new
let's see bread it went to the Russians
twice and Obama went was once to tell
them take a look what I find it
particularly inexplicable is that they
talked to the Russians but not to the
presidential campaign not August 4th
Brennan braced the head of Russian
intelligence he calls the head of
Russian intelligence and says we know
what you're up to you better stop it he
did it again later in August and then
President Obama talked to President
Putin in in September and said we know
what you're up to you better cut it out
so they they go and confront the
Russians clearly or the bad guys and
they won't go and talk to the Companions
and say you know what is this a bath
I'll have more fell Vladimir a lot more
flexibility after that election Oh
instead of briefing the president his
campaign at the time were members on his
team about a possible threat this is
pretty
lievable brennan obama others call me
use their meetings with the Trump
campaign and transition team secretly
collecting evidence on Trump and warning
the Russians a set up an insurance
policy from the get-go but let not your
hearts be troubled because Barre and
Orem clearly clearly are speaking out
for a reason they obviously it's not
hard to figure out no things we do not
know and they're now official criminal
investigation is beyond serious and I
would believe justice is about to be
served it will take time
I'm not making any time predictions
because well I thought that the Horowitz
report would probably be out last May
now tonight the president he has every
reason to be confident that those who
have grossly abused their power those
that have been corrupt in 2016 and
beyond will in fact ultimately be held
accountable to the fullest extent of the
law